en su momento los juegos de sigilo eran
uno de los géneros mejor cuidados de los
videojuegos teniendo grandes exponentes
como metal gear solid o hitman
pero para mí siempre hubo uno que se
destacó sobre los demás quise es sprint
tercero nada que el juego las lucecitas
verdes un protagonista cuyas habilidades
piernas eran incomparables llegando un
nivel del que sólo estén power sería
capaz
splinter cereales de esas áreas que son
tan buenas que aún te preguntas por qué
[ __ ] no ha salido otro juego es decir
ubisoft cabrón ya tienes 3 millones de
estos y no muy buenos precisamente danos
al menos uno de estos el género exigido
es un género que lastimosamente con el
tiempo se ha ido descuidando bastante
pero eso no quiere decir que lo hayamos
olvidado pues hoy precisamente puedo
hablar de uno de estos juegos que
pertenece a una de las mejores sagas de
este género más precisamente conviction
un gran juego que llevaría la saga una
nueva generación introduciendo nuevas
mecánicas y un gameplay mucho más fluido
además contando con una historia que le
haría más profundidad a nuestro
protagonista ahora sí sé qué convicción
a pasar a ser excelente no es el mejor
juego de la sale a todos nos gusta mucho
más doble siendo el grandioso que josh
yuri pro pesar de que adoro toda la
franquicia de momento sólo quiero cubrir
los dos juegos más recientes de la saga
tal vez en otra ocasión hable de los
demás juegos tal vez eso siempre
significa que no acompañen a explorar
este gran juego de esta grandiosa saga
vamos a ver 10 curiosidades secretos y
detalles de splinter cell conviction
una pista sobre sara mientras que el
juego de cabeza
qué es lo que sabe esté sana
durante la primera misión del juego
podemos ver a un hombre leyendo un
periódico en donde estará un artículo
con la ficha policial de sham que obtuvo
en doble agent
a lo largo de todo el juego podemos
encontrar varios peluches de los rabbids
esos conejos raros y cabezones que
ubisoft creo como dije al principio del
vídeo uno de los mejores juegos y nos
que el mejor juego de la saga es sin
duda alguna que os theory que al parecer
un show lo tiene muy presente pues le
hizo una pequeña referencia en este
juego ya que en la misión en donde
visitas el monumento a washington
podemos encontrar aquellos que jordi
como un premio en una de las atracciones
ubisoft quería que este juego sintiera
como algo nuevo para la saga y para
cumplir este objetivo cambiaron algunos
aspectos del gameplay introduciendo por
primera vez algunas mecánicas a la saga
como la opción de marcar y ejecutar el
hecho de que el juego te muestra la
última posición en la que fuiste visto
por tu enemigo pero además de eso creo
que la historia de este juego fuera más
personal y humanizar más a nuestro
protagonista es por eso que optaron por
dejar hasta mucho más desprotegido
dejándolos en su característico traje y
sin la mayoría de su equipo
a pesar de ser un juego publicado hace
más de 10 años tiene bastante afición al
detalle pues la mayoría de sus entornos
en vez de hacer simples mapas sin vida
ni nada especial tienen características
con las que puedes interactuar como por
ejemplo fuegos artificiales que si les
disparan los encenderán y arrastra
exploten
[Aplausos]
en una de las últimas misiones del juego
cuando vamos de camino a la casa blanca
podremos encontrarnos con una señal en
memoria a ariel rubin un diseñador de
ubisoft que creó algunos mapas para el
juego no es que el tipo día muerto ni
nada solo le pareció divertido agregarse
a sí mismo de alguna manera el juego
usualmente el modo cooperativo la
mayoría de los juegos es simplemente la
misma campaña individual solo que
adecuada para dos jugadores pero
curiosamente en este juego decidieron
hacer algo distinto y crear una historia
propia para la campaña cooperativa
siendo esta historia un prólogo para la
campaña principal
al final de la campaña cooperativa uno
de los protagonistas archive
lastimosamente muere y algo interesante
es que durante la historia principal con
sam podemos encontrar su cuerpo en la
mansión de kobin e incluso podremos oír
a unos guardias mencionar los brevemente
mientras hablan
sí
y sé que la mayoría de personas no
tienen suficiente paciencia como para
comerse 20 minutos de créditos después
de terminar el juego pero si lo haces
podrá subir una conversación secreta
entre vic y sham en donde recuerdan una
misión que tuvieron juntos y en algún
momento alguien trató de venderle un
elefante a sham
te dejo pero la parte en la que miramos
el interior del país
bueno eso fue después y lo único que
hicimos fue de cargarnos el general de
la junta provisional y evitar una
inclusión era de lado
que no especifica en el cruce del río y
pescar el seguro más grande del mundo
pero él da igual a lo que importa qué
fue lo que pasó en batalla tienes que
contar esa batalla está siempre cada vez
que puedo
el caso es que estábamos en el mar y 500
en turistas cuando se acerca un tipo
vertido desde luego no sabía elegir bien
a sus clientes porque tomó a sanz por un
primo le pasa a muchos o lo que él si
fuera contada y bueno pues eso así que
llega el tipo se acerca
me mira fijamente y la pregunta si
quiere comprar un elefante
un elefante adulto y qué más da el
tamaño
el río intentaba venderle a sam un
elefante
plantado mirando como si no supiera qué
hacer
era la primera vez que le veía así
estaba pensando cómo iba a decirle será
que no ha comprado a un elefante así que
sanz se vuelve y le dice los que es que
ya tengo uno así sin más tan tranquilo y
el otro se lo cree le decía eso le
rompió el brazo creo que tomé una buena
decisión
el equipo desarrollador de convección
quería que en este juego la historia se
sintiera más real y peligrosa que en
otros juegos y sobre todo querían que
ésta estuviera mucho más al descubierto
y vulnerable es por eso que inicialmente
tuvieron la idea de dejar a sham sin
ningún equipo en absoluto teniendo
únicamente una pistola
además también planearon eliminar el
sistema de cobertura en las sombras para
este juego y hacer que sham se
escondiera a plena vista mezclándose con
multitudes o disfrazándose pero después
de pensarlo decidieron cambiar todo esto
ya que las ideas no eran malas pero no
tendrían la esencia de un sprinter cell
se sentiría muy distinto a las mecánicas
ya características de la saga fue por
eso que decidieron dejar a sam oculto en
las sombras de la mayoría de su equipo
para el juego
durante el final del juego mientras
entregamos atom grid el juego nos dará
la opción de golpearlo o dispararle
varias veces durante el interrogatorio
si decidimos no golpearlo y dispararle
tres veces seguidas veremos como al
morir el cuerpo de ruiz mostrará las
tres heridas de bala en lugares muy
específicos de su cuerpo lo cual fue
diseñado intencionalmente por uso para
que las tres heridas de bala emular las
tres luces de las gafas de visión
nocturna de sham que son una marca
característica de la saca
lucius walker es un personaje bastante
importante en la trama del juego y en
cierto punto sanz puede interrogarlo
amablemente en washington
pero antes de que pueda decirle algo es
asesinado por alguien desconocido pero
claro la culpa recae sobre sam así que
termina huyendo de ahí o mientras escapa
de la escena podemos demostrar un
detalle genial que le agregaron al juego
es cambiante una radio nos damos cuenta
de que hacer que lo encubrió el
asesinato de caler para mantenerse
ocultos y falsamente lo anuncien como un
ataque al corazón
y
por medio de amor
como yo
es una pena que este juego y la saga
splinter cell en general sino tan buena
tenga tan pocos datos curiosos pero de
igual manera espero que estos diez datos
también resultados muy interesantes como
dije antes esta franquicia es una de las
mejores en cuanto a juegos de sigilo y
espero que pronto puedan sacarla del
olvido y traernos un nuevo juego tal vez
menos de estos y un poco más de esto
pero ya veremos hasta la próxima
[Música]